[Música]
la economía mundial sufre en alza los
precios de varios subproductos uno de
los principales problemas de esta crisis
es la que la crisis que hay en la cadena
de suministros global es generada por la
red la rápida activación de la economía
tras la crisis de la pandemia debido a
esto la tasa interanual de inflación en
eeuu se disparó en el mes pasado de
octubre hasta 6.2 por ciento lo que
supone el registro más alto de los
precios de consumo en ese país desde
1990 en medio de la fuerte demanda de
los consumidores se trata del quinto mes
consecutivo en el que la inflación
interanual se sitúa en eeuu por encima
del 5% para ello quiero saludar entonces
a nuestro segundo invitado el día de ese
de claudio loser ex director del fondo
monetario internacional para el
hemisferio occidental
claudio gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
él le preguntó entonces cómo afecta al
resto de la región el hecho de que los
precios en eeuu estén totalmente
disparados y cada inflación esté en su
punto más alto de los últimos 30 años
bueno evidentemente eso tiene un impacto
inmediato sobre
sobre el resto del mundo preserven en
américa latina por dos razones
porque bueno hay una demanda fuerte por
bienes en los eeuu y eso ha llevado a
que los precios de las materias primas
hayan subido el ser precio del petróleo
o sea la gasolina por cierto el precio
de los metales
hablemos de del cobre que está en alta
demanda y donde problemas de producción
y por otro lado están las interrupciones
de la cadena de valor en automóviles y
todo eso entonces eso pensando en un
país
no puedo hablar de un país típico
latinoamericano porque no hay raíz y
pico con latinoamericanos pero
en algún país digamos pero de pronto se
encuentran que las importaciones que
tienen que hacer
suben de precio la gasolina todo eso va
se va a subir de precio autos importados
también y si importan alimentos o
exportan alimentos también va a pegar
por ese lado y hay elementos de corto
plazo
que yo todavía tengo esperanza de que
sea así los precios que han estado
subiendo como digo de autos usados auto
nuevo de alquileres etcétera que eso se
puede esperar que suba que pare perdón
pero haya una tendencia también a
presiones por el lado de salarios que
podrían complicar las cosas más ahora
claudio también estos precios altos
llevan entonces a los bancos por
supuesto a subir las tasas de interés es
esto como nos afecta a nosotros los
ciudadanos y también como qué
implicaciones tiene en las principales
economías
bueno todo el impacto
de en tasas de interés en varia
la reserva federal el banco central de
los estados unidos todavía no ha subido
las tasas de interés porque piensan que
todavía no hay indicaciones de que la
inflación lleve para largo yo creo que
ya tiene que actuar pero las otras tasas
están subiendo entonces qué pasa
en nuestras tarjetas de crédito
de pronto van a poder tener una tasa más
alta aunque las tarjetas de crédito por
lo menos han estado unidos tiene unas
tasas ya muy altas pero si estamos
pensando en la adquisición de bienes
inmuebles de una casa en las hipotecas
que han estado y todavía siguen a tasas
de interés de quizás 34 por ciento estas
hipotecas van a van a subir estoy casi
seguro que van a subir
no quizá en las próximas semanas pero en
los próximos meses eso hace que el
pagaron la hipoteca el sube de precio y
eso evidentemente va a tener un impacto
sobre los presionas casas pero
evidentemente el impacto sobre los
consumidores que viven con crédito va a
ser inmediato ahora también la
secretaria el tesoro de eeuu anticipó
que estos altos precios esta inflación
va a estar hasta finales del próximo año
2022 que deben hacer entonces las
autoridades para resolver este problema
esa situación para que no se sigue
entonces presentando un interés una
inflación perdón tan alta
bueno
debo decir como economista que muchas
veces el poder de control no de
controlar los precios sino de controlar
la inflación lleva algún tiempo no es
inmediato
pero lo primero que tienen que
solucionar es este problema de la cadena
de producción o la cadena de valor es
tratar de hacer que en los puertos y no
solamente en los estados unidos estamos
hablando en todos lados pueda haber un
movimiento
puede haber un movimiento mayor ayudar
por ese lado es muy poco lo que puede
hacer el gobierno aquí en eeuu por la
presión en el mercado laboral el mercado
laboral es donde está la cosa complicada
favorable para por supuesto los
trabajadores
y desfavorable para las empresas porque
hay de alguna manera hay una percepción
por los trabajadores que pueden
conseguir mejores trabajos lo cual puede
ser en el corto plazo pero eso el
gobierno es muy poco lo que puede hacer
esto hay que saber que tener un poco de
paciencia
lamentablemente
pero van a tener que trabajar primero
subiendo las tasas de interés segundo
darle muy duro en términos de la cadena
de valor no solamente en eeuu estamos
hablando de europa estamos hablando de
china estamos hablando de de japón
también claudio como ve entonces la
economía global haciendo como un resumen
para dónde podemos ir en los próximos
meses que podemos esperar sobre todo
también aquí en nuestra región américa
latina y recordemos que también estamos
en un contexto en un mundo que pues está
saliendo de una pandemia apenas estamos
en la fase de recuperación económica en
todos los países del mundo entonces como
ves la situación mundial
bueno
lo que se espera y los últimos estudios
del fondo monetario banco mundial la
ocde es que siga expandiéndose la
economía en el año 21 la expansión es
muy fuerte en el año 22 va a ser menor
porque este año ha sido especial o sea
salvo estos temas que hemos hablado se
espera que él siga y siga
regularizándose la situación el tema es
el siguiente en eeuu el crecimiento de
fuerte en europa un poco más atrasado
pero en américa latina y aunque ha
habido una recuperación importante
va a demorar un poco más
hay problemas de política macroeconómica
en brasil en méxico - en argentina por
cierto mucho más en colombia también en
términos de la pandemia y todo eso hace
que la recuperación funcione y no hay
duda de que va a funcionar pero yo diría
que va a ser hacia fines del 22 que y
principios del 23 que vamos a ver una
regularización pero yo soy optimista lo
que pasa que no es la la cuesta arriba
la subida no es
sana sino que hay piedras en el camino
sí lo puedo poner en términos muy muy de
todos los días bueno claudio muchísimas
gracias entonces por su análisis por
entender un poco lo que está ocurriendo
con esa inflación como además nos va a
afectar a nosotros en nuestros países
latinoamericanos y para dónde vamos un
poco no ya pues teniendo en cuenta lo
que usted dijo esperemos que finales de
2022 ya pues la economía mundial puede
estar un poco más estable más
regularizada